a computer's embarks price of 3600 side
recommended retail price 3600 what's the
total cost I really want you guys to be
able to don't have to say I don't have
this question because he never showed us
right I want to be able to show you and
they give you descriptions the terms
okay so the terms say this is my total
cost help you outside don't have to keep
on looking down I'm 42 dollars 92 how
frequently do we have to pay per what
wait per week so how many weeks are
there in a year 500 people - how many
years - I got it right so you can
multiply just by legend for that I give
you know someone's already worked it out
who's got thousand say that's right okay
stay with me so there you go that's the
total cost per computer on those terms
now then they hold you're here through
this next part how much interest has
been paid that's the difference between
this what we actually pay and what it's
worth right so the interest is is this -
this the total - the retail in fact I
might even write that total - retail
okay so that's four for six 360 a I have
- and now give us the eight hundred and
something blue right okay now what is
this song this is how much extra we had
to pay for the privilege of paying
slowly right for the privilege of
getting the computer right away even
though we hadn't paid off the whole lot
okay so now part C it says how much is
interest is paid per year because you
know what we're doing I'm borrowing and
loads interest is always a rate per
annum right it's not the total over the
whole time it's per annum so they say
our interest so and I'm even going to
write that per
and that's per year right there were two
years that I divide this by so it's
going to be eight hundred sixty three
sixty eight divided by however many
number of years if I paid over five
years I'll divide by five for paid over
ten years I divide by ten you get the
idea okay what's it going to be it's
four hundred and I read the scale for
3184 I can then go that's interest per
annum as a dollar values right per year
Anna means like annual yeah yeah good
okay what's the percentage interest rate
percentage interest rate so can you see
our total then interest which involves
the total interest per annum now I'm
going to go percentage its interest by
the way okay yeah so you take this which
is how much they charge me every year
for 3184 and what I divide by is the
original costs a recommended retail so
you divide by 3,600 and then I think
after you round off you get you get zero
point one one nine nine blah blah blah
co person